sogar gefahr ist ja gewohnt also ich
nichts melanie m möchte wissen warum wir
unsere eigenen führte eigentlich gar
nicht so schlimm finden eine wunderbare
frage und ein super smalltalk thema für
die nächste wg party zunächst mal warum
furzen wir überhaupt ein mensch vor zehn
bis 20 mal pro tag das sind weltweit so
75 bis 150 milliarden 14 pro tag
die gase aus denen ein furz besteht
kommen hauptsächlich aus zwei quellen
erstens überschüssige luft die wir das
essen zu uns nehmen und zweitens die
luft oder die gase die entstehen wenn
unser essen im darm kommentiert wird für
den gestank sind schwefelhaltige
moleküle verantwortlich die von unserer
dickdarm flora beim verarbeiten des
essens produziert werden zb das molekül
h2s schwefelwasserstoff das nach
verfaulten eiern riecht weitere stinky
moleküle findet ihr in dieser
wundervollen die infografik von compound
interest wo körpergerüche chemisch
runter gebrochen werden link in der
beschreibung ansonsten bestehen führt
sie aus geruchslosen gasen hauptsächlich
wasserstoff stickstoff und co2 deshalb
gilt auch die faustregel je lauter ein
furz desto weniger stinktier da eine
hohe pumps lautstärke mit einem größeren
gasvolumen einhergeht was bedeutet dass
die sticky moleküle stärker verdient
sind bevor wir weitermachen möchte ich
ganz gut eure aufmerksamkeit auf die
wissenschafter lenken dank denen wir das
ja alles überhaupt wissen denkt ihr so
eine furt zusammensetzung lässt sich
theoretisch erleiden nein das wurde
alles experimentell bestimmt in dieser
studie zum beispiel wurden kurz proben
von probanden gesammelt zuvor boni
gegessen hatten ja dann wurden die
inhaltsstoffe dieser kurz proben anhand
von gas chromatographie bestimmt und
zuletzt wurden diese foods boom
wertungsrichtern vorgelegt welche diese
anhand einer skala von null geruchslos
ist 8 o pen sie bewerten sollten
true story alles für die wissenschaft
jedenfalls warum empfinden wir diese
gerüche überhaupt als unangenehm
unschöne gerüchte sind oft ein
gesundheitliches warenzeichen übliche
körperausscheidungen sind potenzielle
her dafür krankheitsüberträger die
möglichst gemieden werden sollen hat man
allerdings eltern so empfinden die die
windeln ihre eigenen babys deutlich
angenehmer als die windeln von fremden
babys und auch hier hilft uns unsere
wagemut dabei uns gut um unseren
nachwuchs zu kümmern und was ist jetzt
mit unseren eigenen kürzen naja der
geruch unserer eigenen führt servierten
maßgeblich von unserer eigenen darmflora
bestimmt die uns nicht nur wohl bekannt
sondern auch die einzigartige stürze
sind ein bisschen wie stinkende
fingerabdrücke da jeder mensch sein
einzigartiges set an bakterien hat
und bei 14 gilt dasselbe wie in vielen
anderen teilen des lebens nämlich was
wir kennen das mögen wir
hinzu kommt ein psychologischer effekt
denn wenn ich selbst kurze bin ich ja
auf den folgenden gestalt vorbereitet
aber wenn ich von einem fremden kurz
überrascht werde dann empfinde ich
diesen schon allein wegen der
überraschung als deutlich unangenehmer
schön schlau
vielen dank noch mal an melanie m führte
eine frage wie geht es euch fehlt ihr
eure eigenen kürze auch nicht so schlimm
oder vielleicht doch oder gehört sie zu
den allgemeinen berufs unempfindlichen
menschen schreibt sie in die kommentare
wir sehen uns nächste woche bis dahin
hält sich